7h30 une journée comme une autre
quelque part dans paris 7h30
mais quand julie emilie s'éveille leur
maman est déjà prêt depuis longtemps
l'accord est tacite le premier à billets
s'occupe des enfants
mais comme par hasard valérie gagnent
souvent à ce petit jeu là les
intercalaires 8h15
toute la famille sur le chemin de
l'école rituel immuable le p'tit bonheur
du matin 8h45 retour à la maison et
répartition naturelle des tâches
contrairement aux apparences la question
de paresser c'est à la minute près faire
que tout doit se faire vite de façon à
arriver
pas trop tard au bureau je serais tenté
de rester ici de m'asseoir et on le
journal et plus bouger 9h30
arrivé au bureau c'est ici en terrain
neutre que la confidence se fait tout
naturellement
je pense que les femmes en font beaucoup
plus que les hommes mais c'est
certainement la faute des femmes aussi
pourquoi parce qu'on laisse peut-être
pas le temps aux hommes de de faire
parce qu'on doit trouver qu'à chaque
fois c'est pas bien fait que c'est pas
fait comme il faut donc on le fait nous
mêmes
moi j'ai eu un papa qui ne savaient pas
où était une casserole j'ai toujours vu
ma mère tout faire la maison et je pense
que certainement ça se retrouve après le
dit votre look à la terre a dormi
la journée de travail fut dans ce n'est
pas le temps d'y penser 19h30 la machine
s'emballe à nouveau après les devoirs le
bain le dîner et le petit moment pour
soi on l'a à quelle heure 10 heures le
temps de ranger de faire un dîner est
affranchi du coup chez les filles
pire il lui aura apporté sa modeste
contribution
mais on le sait c'est le geste qui
compte